quienes ustedes fueron a la universidad
quienes aprendieron más en la
universidad que en su primer trabajo
muy pocos no todos fuimos estas
instituciones académicas y pocos nos
hemos preguntado de dónde salieron quién
las inventó y por qué comenzaron yo si
universidad viene del latín universitas
magisterio med escolar yo les podría
decir que significa pero usted lo puede
nublar así que mi me da igual
esta palabra en latín nació en el año
1000 88 cuando se fundó a la universidad
de bolonia la universidad de bolonia fue
el primer centro académico europeo donde
se juntaba el conocimiento la idea era
que cada ciudad europea tuviera su
centro donde se generara se resguardará
y se diseminar el conocimiento fue así
que durante el año 1100 se fueron
creando diferentes universidades como la
universidad de parís la universidad de
oxford la universidad de milán entre
muchas otras
pasaron así muchos años como 700 y
fueron año 1800 que llegó a la
revolución industrial
con esto cambio muchas cosas entre ellos
la llegada de las máquinas a las
fábricas
fue así y conforme la gente se empezó a
quedar sin empleo se fueron a las calles
justamente y entonces los gobiernos
europeos se preguntaban qué hacemos con
todos estos jóvenes que tienen 18 años
normalmente los mandaremos a trabajar
pero no hay suficientes empleos y
creyeron que era una buena idea
masificar las universidades y que
estudiarán cuatro años más y así en
cuatro años nos preocuparemos del
problema
de poco a poco se fueron clasificando
las universidades y hoy a nivel global
hay más de 40 mil centros de
instituciones de educación superior
pero volviendo me pregunto al final para
que existían cuál es su objetivo
en 1100 era resguardar el conocimiento
muchos de los cuales estaban en libros
sobre todo antes de que existiera la
imprenta
en 1800 era ocupar a los jóvenes para
que no fueran delincuentes si no
estuvieran en la calle y la pregunta es
para qué sirve la universidad hoy
hace tres años le preguntamos una serie
de reactores de méjico y nos dijeron
algo muy sencillo para prepararnos para
el trabajo
veamos incierto en nuestro país cada año
se gradúan casi 600 mil ingenieros y en
los últimos 10 años este número se ha
ido incrementando en un 88 por ciento
uno pensaría que más ingenieros más
licenciados hay mayor prosperidad
económica no el ingreso promedio en
méxico está completamente estable ya
incluso ha bajado 20 por ciento en
términos reales
entonces algo no está cuadrando la
gráfica de grados va para arriba la
gráfica de ingreso está completamente
estable
que estamos haciendo bien que estamos
haciendo mal
creo yo que hay tres problemas
importantes que hay que atacar
el primero
vivimos en un sistema educativo
completamente lineal porque porque se
creó justo con las fábricas
acompañen un segundo uno entre las siete
de la mañana
así check-in trabaja a las diez y media
suena el timbre
vamos el recreo comes algo suena el
timbre regresas
trabajas sales a las 3 de la tarde
lo que acabo de mencionar podría ser una
fábrica o podría ser el salón de la
universidad y realmente es lo mismo
porque se crearon bajo la misma premisa
entonces las fábricas de 1800 claramente
no se ven igual que las fábricas de hoy
y sin embargo los salones se siguen
viendo exactamente igual
regresemos a que hacen las fábricas de
hoy distintas hay miles de
organizaciones que están cada vez
trabajando de forma distinta y se ha
poner un par de ejemplos no
ahora no estés de un lado o del otro
simplemente son instituciones distintas
es decir las fábricas del pasado tener
una visión pegada en la pared a las
fábricas de hoy tiene un propósito las
fábricas del pasado eran predecibles
confiables manejaban los riesgos hoy las
fábricas toman riesgos calculados las
fábricas del pasado terminar yo fijo de
oficina hoy tiene una reflex ible y
sobre todo las fábricas del pasado
tienen equipos jerárquicos y hoy tenemos
equipos multidisciplinarios auto
regulados
si estamos necesitando cosas del futuro
como se ve la gente en ese futuro y
claramente hay un empleado del pasado y
un empleado del hoy el empleado del
pasado que en méxico muchos le llamamos
el godín y trabaja de 9 a 6 de la tarde
el empleado de hoy trabaja por objetivos
el empleado el pasado trabaja en su
oficina con su computadora de la empresa
el empleado de hoy trabaja desde donde
pueda y usa cualquier dispositivo
el trabajo en el empleado de ayer se
enfoca mucho en los inputs en que está
haciendo el empleado de hoy se enfoca en
que está saliendo y sobre todo se
enfocan anteriormente en el conocimiento
y hoy en el aprender a aprender
no es que tú puedas escoger a yo no
puedo hacer lo de la derecha entonces me
quedo con las empresas de la izquierda
no porque todas estas empresas están
migrando a hacer empresas y fábricas del
hoy porque porque sino ellas mismas
desaparecen
segundo problema tenemos un sistema
educativo pasivo vamos a hacer un
pequeño quiz quien descubre américa
buenísimo 'cristóbal colón' quien
descubrió la luna más grande de saturno
la verdad
qué pasa que el sistema educativo está
basado en que nos enseñen un verbo
completamente pasivo cuántas veces
escuchamos en el examen maestra esto no
lo vimos en clase
ustedes saben quiénes son
y entonces como el sistema nos enseñan
en vez de que nosotros aprendamos suelo
completamente pasivo cuando aprender es
un verbo activo
así el profesor hace una pregunta
levanta la mano y esperamos que los
alumnos tengan la respuesta porque el
sistema se basa en tener la respuesta
correcta del libro de texto y tú no
puedes preguntar como alumno porque la
autoridad la que pregunta el profesor
realmente es el profesor pregunta uno
toma nota que memoriza es algo respondes
el examen saca acción otra vez eso
quiere decir que te enseñaron no quieren
decir que aprendiste
cómo se vería la educación si lo que
pasara fuera más o menos lo siguiente el
profesor plante una pregunta el joven
plantea una pregunta un poco más
interesante y la reflexionan sus
compañeros lo investigan en internet
hacen una hipótesis inicial y la válida
sin embargo otro compañero es una
pregunta más interesante el profesor las
vuelve a recapitular mucho mejor no
vamos a intentarlo quién descubrió
américa
muy bien porque descubrieron américa
porque tres carabelas y no cuatro como
flotaban las carabelas porque le
pusieron américa y no caravelle ya todo
no cristóbal ya y sobre todo que motiva
los reyes de españa que clase
preferirían
la segunda no
otra vez el enseñar no quiere decir que
estemos aprendiendo
tú aprendes cuando piensas cuando
experimentas cuando válidas cuando
cuestionas cuando haces deshaces y sobre
todo cuando relacionas los conceptos que
estás viendo en clase al mundo real
tercer problema un sistema educativo
completamente desconectado
tradicionalmente pasábamos comer 22 años
de nuestra vida estudiando e intentando
conocer qué íbamos a hacer de nuestras
vidas conociendo gente y sobre todo
entendiendo cómo funcionaba el mundo
para después que trabajar durante 40
años
este modelo claramente ya no aplica
porque porque estudiamos más o menos 18
años y de grande ser menos después a lo
mejor te tomas un año aprendes marketing
digital algo de emprendimiento y
programación de ahí te vas a manejar
redes sociales para una asociación civil
después regresa a la prensa estrategia y
finanzas
entonces el corporativo defensa dos años
después regresas aprendes ciencia de
datos y es un ir y venir entre aprender
y trabajar porque porque si es el mundo
real y sobre todo porque ya no vamos a
trabajar simplemente 40 años
y lo peor de todo es que todas llegamos
al corporativo y nos enseñan que las 4p
no sirven de nada que defensa tiene su
propio framework de marketing y que es
el que tenemos que aprender
y entonces podremos llegar a pensar
bueno todo vale la pena porque es una
experiencia de vida vamos a ver si
financieramente dan los números la
colegiatura promedio en universidad
privada en mexico es más o menos diez
mil once mil pesos si lo multiplicamos
por 48 meses nos dan 530 mil pesos
el graduado promedio de licenciatura en
méxico gana 11 mil pesos casi 12 eso
quiere decir que si nos grabamos y
empezamos a pagar nuestra deuda nos
tardaremos más o menos 44 meses en
pagarla de regreso si gastas un poquito
diez mil pesos al mes y solamente
pagados te vas tarda un poquito más como
268 meses o veintidós años
porque no hacemos de esa matemática
porque latinoamérica la educación es una
herencia y todos nuestros papás son un
esfuerzo tremendo sin importar la clase
social para apoyarnos con el tema
gracias mamá
te gradúas entras a la empresa y a la
empresa todo le cuesta es más porque con
otros no aprendiste nada te tienen que
entrenar y es eso lo que nunca se suma
al retorno de inversión educativa
y sin embargo tenemos la universidad más
increíble del mundo disponible 24 horas
con todos los contenidos del mundo
hace unos segundos el ingeniero de
producción estaba viendo en youtube cómo
conectar nuestra transmisión al link en
vivo aprendiendo lo por sí solo y
entonces si tenemos todo el conocimiento
del mundo para aprender desde hacer
cafés marketing digital ciencia de datos
o simplemente tomar mejores fotos porque
no lo hacemos porque nadie nos enseñó a
aprender
deberían estar preocupados si tienes
menos de 20 años no te preocupes tú
naciste digital sobre la paz en youtube
y lo vas a hacer si tienen más de 55
tampoco tienes que preocupar mucho la
vas a liberar a retirarte sin tener que
ver este relajo
si tienes como yo entre 20 y 55
preocupante porque te educo un sistema
lineal las organizaciones quieren
empleados exponenciales y no estamos
preparados no se preocupen les voy a
decir cómo
primero aprendamos a aprender qué
significa esto
desarrollar lo que yo llamo las cuatro
veces el pensamiento crítico la
comunicación la colaboración que no es
nada más entre nosotros los humanos sino
con las máquinas y sobre todo la
creatividad si aprendemos a pensar a
colaborar a comunicarnos y a ser
creativos es muy probable que podamos
estar continuamente reinventándonos
segundo
y aprender de manera activa y relevante
cómo se hace eso primero interesándonos
lo que vamos a aprender descubran un
problema que les interese de ahí
pregunten una buena pregunta váyanse a
buscar mejores preguntas y mejores
respuestas hay muchos contenidos
disponibles hay mentores hay gente que
sabe hacer las cosas o que lo ha hecho y
sobre todo gente que tiene muchas
experiencias aprendizajes de los cuales
uno puede aprender y por último
identifique el nuevo problema igual van
a hacer
y por último repite siempre estamos en
beta así como apple lanza un modelo de
iphone cada año tenemos que estar
continuamente reinventando los siempre
en beta porque porque antes valoramos el
ser que éramos no entonces una mamá
presume orgullosamente mi hijo y es
doctor mi hijo es arquitecto mi hijo es
ingeniero y pensábamos que ya lo
habíamos hecho de por vida sin embargo
hoy el mejor doctor probablemente no es
el que tiene 40 años dando consultas
esté extendiendo los últimos
procedimientos que está actualizando
continuamente y sobre todo que está
aprendiendo es decir hoy yo no soy
ingeniero o yo soy emprendedor soy
educador soy mentor soy profesor y soy
muchas cosas más pero es lo que soy hoy
y no lo que voy a hacer mañana ni lo que
fue ayer
tenemos que aprender a estar siendo y no
simplemente hacer
por último quisiera cerrar con una de
mis frases favoritas de marc andreessen
un reconocido inversionista en silicon
valley que plantea la situación muy
sencilla existen dos tipos de personas
aquellas que les van a decir qué hacer a
las máquinas con su trabajo y aquellos a
las que las máquinas les van a decir qué
hacer
otra vez va más claro personas que les
dicen que hacer a las máquinas y
máquinas que les dicen que hacer a las
personas de qué lado quieres estar
si crees que no te va a pasar a ti que
tú vas a poder terminar y retirarte
antes de que todo esto cambie no te
equivoques hoy es el día más lento del
resto de tu vida y solo se va a acelerar
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]